ο καθένας συναι σπίτι του οπότε μεχρειάζουνται ξέγουν ότι είναι εκεί και θα είναι δίπλα
τους και θα του στη ρίξω στις δύσκολες στιγμές τους που ο καθένας πεγνά κάποια
στιγμή κάτι πιο θοβαεγώ από καθημερινότητα αλλάέχουμε μια καλή καλήσιέση θα με θα μ θα
μεβωτήσουν την ιδέα μου γιαδιάφογα πράματα αλλά δεν επενδαίνω καθένας έχει τη ζωή του τι
κρατάται από τον αναστάσειο λεβέντη που σας συντροφεύει με χρισήμερα θρατό ότο ότι το ασάνθρωπος
που ήταν πραγματικά άνθώπος που βοηθούσε και κίνο στον κόσμο διότι ότανεν ξεκίνης με το
θέματο ν υπότοφιο ήταν πριν να γίνει το ίδρημα λευέντη δηλαδή εεκίνησε και βοηθούσε φιτητές
που ήταν στη γαλία πολύ πριν να ξεκινήσει το ίδρεμα γι ότι το ίδριμα δημιογήθηκε
μετά το θάνατο το και ο πρώτος ποεδώς ήταν κοστανίνος λευέντης και έτσι βλεπα αυτή
τη τιν αγάπη που είχε για τον για το κόσμο για τους νέους και νομίζω
αυτό με επηρέασε καιολας και ίσωκαι γι αυτό ασχολήθηκα και εγομε με διάφορα ηδρήματα και
με τον κόσμο γιενικότε ασχολίστεο και το επάμε και στην αρχή μετα υδρήματα δυστυχώς ηκρίση
δεν έχει φύγει και τός κόσμος ζήσι τα όρια της στόχιας και σε ενέργειες γίνονται
από πλε βρά σας είτε μέσο το ελεθρο σταύρου ώστε να αντιμετωπιστεί αυτό όσο γίνεται
περισσόταεμείς διδικάσαν ναριθώ σταυρώς έχουμε παργαπολύ κόσμο που έρχεται στο